[Music]
yo its C Mon I'm hanging out with JK
news so in my bad news submitted by boss
levels Japan is now apologizing and
compensating victims of forced
sterilization what do I do to China
Korea with Japanese people see people
think Japanese people are all [ __ ] up
it's like come on man they do it to
their own - maybe that's why they won't
apologize the like but we do it to our
own people so it's like it's not racist
if you do it to your own kind that's
true Japan for sterilized but they have
a population issue right now or decline
so this for sterilization happened was
the for dumb people exactly that's kind
of smart though but who's the fool but
who's to say that you're smart or dumb
oh that's true cuz they believe or maybe
dumb in one area but really smart in
another I would have been sterilized if
I was in Japan yeah you see that sucks
cuz you're not done something different
48 in 1996 there's a law that was aimed
to prevent the birth of poor quality
descendant and there were about a
century Wow there were about sixteen
thousand five hundred people that were
mostly women with disabilities that got
sterilized what eight thousand other
people I gave consent but they were most
likely under pressure to give that
consent right and there were almost
60,000 women who had abortions because
of hereditary illnesses if you are dumb
as [ __ ] like dumbest [ __ ] rocks like
you even knew you're kind of stupid
that's not hard for me to uh get in that
mindset okay you're not dumb as rocks
you're stupid
so here done it rocks right and then the
government had this program and they're
okay well we're gonna sterilize you but
you get fifteen thousand dollars from
the government
would you do it how long fifteen dollars
just done cuz Sarah lies you but here's
the few thousand but you're dumb as [ __ ]
but I've always wanted a family I am
like dumb people still want babies and
children and day need I mean they could
still work we're not are we talking
about severely
disabled people that are being
sterilized are we just talking about
when they say undesirable you know is it
like oh you come from a shitty trashy
family I think it actually might have
been more genetic like yeah maybe
looking at hereditary illnesses this
runs in your family just straight up
eugenics like they did inspired a nation
grace yeah well I just want to be
compensated for I got my family got
diabetes so [ __ ] we could have got it to
the diabetes or maybe if it wasn't even
that it was more like serious [ __ ] this
girl she was diagnosed with quote
hereditary feeble-mindedness
see that's what I'm saying they making
[ __ ] up yeah so she was sterilized
because of that and they were she was 15
at that time in 1972 Loretta Terry
feeble-mindedness
that means like your whole family is
[ __ ] fickle and stupid yeah and so
they were sterilizing people as young as
nine years old oh my god yeah I wasn't
for some reason what I hear sterilizing
people I kind of just pictured the guys
game that he takes to I don't think the
women for some reason yeah what do you
do you take out their ovaries yeah we
tie the tubes
yeah maybe do that or I don't know the
way they did it so snip snip a dude yeah
I mean because I believe in sterilizing
rapist rapist yeah they carry their sex
drive - yeah I believe in that I believe
do you know how in some countries they
they like chop off the woman's [ __ ] so
she doesn't have pleasure there's like
certain African tribe yeah why would
they do such a thing it's like female
circumcision they almost circle music
divergent equivalent where you can't
general numeration no but they can take
away your hormones I think the closest
thing that just actual I take your
testes away yeah I think eunuchs are the
closest thing the noble yes are an
episode of the good doctor where there
was a girl Lord bear at her being
circumcised
right and it was through like I guess
like them in their tribe they do that to
a young girl and it was her grandmother
that did it to her this isn't real no
this is a TV show but it's based on like
real medical stuff that's happened or
something like that and I learned about
ya see and then I guess like they
reconstructed her clitoris for her to
feel pleasure again but her parents
didn't want her to do that because it
was like against what their tradition
was so the dog did it without their
parents consent and reconstructed told
that they did it and the girl said thank
you what do you use for that
so they used a part of her inside of her
cheek and grafted it to recreate the one
that I saw they used it was nip/tuck the
one that I saw it was like the tip of
her toe like the freaking this part of
her leg pinky toe
that's what things are very quickly I
don't know what I like to show the good
doctor not because it's like a serious
show I like it because the main doctor
he has a severe form of autism but he's
a genius
but because of he's very crass so he'll
come in walling house like no he'll be
like this because he doesn't understand
like social cues in normal stuff so
welcome to a kid you have cancer that
makes me laugh dude it makes me [ __ ]
up the people you're gonna die tomorrow
maybe they shouldn't let him deliver the
news they're trying to teach him how to
beat it it's actually based off a Korean
drama yes yeah which is kind of crazy
because the Korean one sucked ass Oh
specifically because I don't think that
actor did his study on what may be a
severely autistic person would be like
but this actor was like a UK actor
[ __ ] kills it good and I've never met
like I know that not by family members
but like people in the church that had
kids who are autistic they kind of sound
they had that same type of like
mannerism solid you have this kind inner
some [ __ ] of research dude so dope dude
I'm not too familiar with advanced what
autism millions I don't know either they
explained it on the show and it was some
fancy-ass words okay so we all just
don't know a developmental disorder a
variable severity that is characterized
by difficulty in social interaction
communication by and by restricted or
repetitive patterns of thought and
behavior that's what is this well I know
this
I guess the behavioral trait of it but
is it caused by physiological or is it I
don't know why people have autism though
right they don't have it I'm pinpointed
the very reason for it because
I know there was they called
anti-vaxxers say that vaccines are the
reason why kids have autism or some [ __ ]
like that
which is kind of odd there's no there's
no scientific grounding for it but
that's like one is their belief system
yeah that's the that's the hill that
they're trying to die on right there
well there was a really dumb
there was a dumb clinician like a long
time ago who falsified some studies
that's that's that's what started the
that's work yeah started from and then
got debunked but then like you know I
guess with the way that the Internet is
now it's just like there's just space
for conspiracy theories because if
you're looking for it you can find it
yeah mm-hmm and and yeah it exists on a
spectrum and some people are incredibly
high functioning and it makes them very
good at certain logical aspects of like
thinking but further at its worst it's
very debilitating it's hard to because
like you would try to talk to like
certain parents who their kids have
these signs of like they might be
autistic I think for a lot of Asian
people they see that and they say that
oh you're saying my kids dumb and they
don't see it as like a medical condition
they probably heard artistic and they're
like hell no he's gonna be a doctor yeah
my kids not artistic because there's no
autistic oh you mean he's gonna be
really good at math yeah yeah oh great
is this weird though cuz they don't see
that as like some they just see it as oh
you call my kid dumb but they don't see
it as like a medical thing that needs to
be addressed because so much my brother
was a behavioral therapist before he
became a nurse and he told me that there
are certain levels of autism that can be
helped if you catch it early enough and
then you could teach him these motor
function or whatever teaching about a
social another young age but a lot of
times that they'll parents don't want to
take that reality they think that it's
they don't they just don't want it to
exist a little denied but they're what
they're what they're [ __ ] up on is
that if there is a chance that that kid
is autistic they could if it's at a low
level they could actually help him be a
little normal when he's older so they
just don't want to deal with it they're
just like out of mind out of sight his
one eye watch this one like documentary
on autism and it was one guy huh he did
it was full papers all day right so he
got a job at this like envelope company
where he would just fold papers into L
envelopes and it's like mass mailing and
[ __ ]
he was really good and doing fast
calculations so he was good at fast math
like it was like yes good math quick
manner yeah all the shapes were the way
that he saw numbers were in the form of
shapes so he would like he would like
she would get play-doh and he'll be like
yeah this is a hundred and fifty three
or whatever oh yeah that's crazy
and that's next level didn't he would go
back to his job and he's having a blast
he loves folding paper he just folds
paper puts it in the envelope folds
paper that's all he does that's awesome
for eight hours a day but that big dough
but it was like an autistic kickboxer
did he probably be really good cuz they
could just hone it on certain pieces
drill all day long [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody
and you just probably just seen people's
bodies be like math equations just
solving less yeah so what is Japan doing
now they're saying like sorry
basically formal and then they're also
they issued like an apology to
themselves to the rating victims and
everyone gets a free beef ball no 3.2
million you about thirty thousand oh
never mind it sounded really $30,000 per
surviving victim and then it says they
don't get that much money in litigation
and suing there's a cap out there so
people don't go sooo crazy
it's always like reasonable amounts I
like that they're saying it's for the
great physical and mental suffering
caused by the forced sterilization
program that they sincerely regret and
that they apologize wholeheartedly yeah
that's uh eugenics pretty recent to
would you say ninety four maybe six
ninety six how recent yeah but they're
you know ages a little outdated when it
comes to mental health and things like
that like my my grandma was at a at a
home for elderly care and a lot of
patients there had Alzheimer's and
dementia and things like that and none
of the staff was equipped with the
understanding of any of those things
like to know just they're just
caretakers like they're all nice and
stuff but I heard I'm talking about the
issues as if like it's a personality
flaw or like it's like their choice of
acting this way and I'm just like what
the [ __ ] you guys are dumb how can you
be
the RN knew but then the RN still had a
very elementary understanding of you
know mental health and stuff hmm so sad
[Music]